President Trump is demanding answers
from Saudi Arabia today a close American
ally over missing Washington Post
contributor several US senators now want
an investigation into the disappearance
rather of Jamal khashoggi is a critic of
the Saudi government who banished more
than a week ago Holly Williams has
reported from Saudi Arabia for years
she's outside the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul Turkey Rakosi
where kosher where kosher gate was last
seen going in but not coming out Holly
good morning good morning The Washington
Post is reporting that before Jamal
keshavjee disappeared US intelligence
may have intercepted communications by
Saudi officials discussing plans to
detain the journalists a State
Department spokesman denied that the
u.s. had any prior knowledge of his
disappearance a Turkish newspaper has
published the names and faces of what it
called a 15 man assassination team that
entered Turkey the same day has shakti
disappeared
we cannot independently verify that
information turkish officials speaking
anonymously have told journalists they
believe ashok ji was murdered inside the
consulate but have provided no
conclusive evidence Saudi Arabia has
denied it keshavjee was an outspoken
critic of the Saudi government and the
country's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman the Trump administration
including president Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner has built a close
relationship with the crown prince if it
is proven that the Saudi government
abducted or killed
Jamal hisagi it will seriously
complicate one of America's most
important relationships here in the
Middle East
bianna that's right Holly quickly
turning into a geopolitical crisis thank
you